[Music]
people say I'm like the white kanye
west's review right now look that's
gotta be him what are you gonna do I'm
gonna tell him if he sells a vape pen to
my brother again I'm gonna kick his ass
hey you oh hey fellas
butters what are you guys doing butters
are you selling fakes
well sure what you're looking for have
that strawberry vanilla tropical passion
what tropical passion it's like mango
and kiwi butters you understand this
stuff is an epidemic in our school yeah
hey five bucks a pop we're gonna be rich
butters this is for care tonight vaping
epidemic at South Park do you think it's
an epidemic for real the FDA does yeah
maybe a lot of kids are doing it but
what's wrong with nicotine I don't there
no like yeah it's addictive but it also
helps ward off Alzheimer's and
Parkinson's this is a real thing but
like if your dick I'm addicted to coffee
whatever who cares kids keep vaping
nicotine I feel like it's crazy to me to
that the industry is like well you know
we're surprised that it started like
being really popular with kids I looked
up the top flavors they are fruit cereal
and ice cream there's a fruit cereal and
an ice cream what adult who isn't a
pedophile wants to put that flavour in
his mouth what that's my like number one
date choices are you want to get ice
cream let's get ice cream is your number
one day to dinner you're an adult
what do you expensive and it's committal
whatever you don't sound like an adult
and then dinners expensive and it's
committal it is camilo what you're gonna
commit to every dinner date that you go
on no crazy take tender dates the ice
cream yeah I took some of the person who
works on like the third floor before I
had the job before
oh hey what's up and she was like I got
you that job stop calling I mean I don't
think that vaping I think nicotine might
be the epidemic that's what they've ate
I know that but I mean people are still
addicted to cigarettes in any way this
is Mogu vaping is the problem cigarettes
marketing to adults as you hit a certain
age you're not going backwards
what deliver what flavor is an adult
flavor to my responsibility having
somewhere to be in people that depend on
you okay that's a flavor it really
tastes awful are you tired today start a
pumpkin spice oil company you make so
much money exist
sounds sound off in the comments if you
would buy pumpkin spice vape oh where
we'll be sending it strictly from us
strictly from us yeah sound off in the
comments of you like Jordans hat that's
a normal do you think it's a little
weird that carbon just punch butters in
the face and the clip usually he has
like elaborate plan to make some kids
eat its parent their parents and all
those other kind of stuff I didn't love
Cartman punching him in the face
I wanted Cartman to do something witty
and he said witty there's a little punch
him in the face I love it that is this
is for care drop all those jewels
everywhere it was like you know I think
they wanted that visual so badly that
means like whatever we have to do to get
to these like beautiful just like little
jewels honestly the most I'm guessing
somebody prior was a sonic fan it was
like I wouldn't know but I'm very good
at stage combat in high school I did a
lot of stage combat you want to stage
slap me I'm sure I don't regular hit me
yeah okay so you have to I forget what
did I turn this way yeah
how dare you talk over me keep it on
camera you and your brothers would just
straight-up fistfight okay put it back
up actually the girl
Jordan data on the third floor Jordan
being our resident butters
we have some more butters clips my
favorite butters clip was the one where
he becomes a pimp
Oh to everybody if you haven't seen it
check this one out
boy oh boy really great work bitches you
also lots of kisses today except for you
me and I'm afraid you get a stormy cloud
sticker today so wait you're keeping all
the money now I just hold on to all the
money cuz pictures can't be trusted with
it
we pull all the kissing money together
she but if you want to buy anything you
just talk to the bottom bitch and then
the bottom bitch talks to me
alright see after school do you know
what I am saying well I'm in with Chef
died on the show for real it was a who
that who's gonna fill chefs by then they
pulled out butters and I was like I love
butter because he he's such a dumb like
he's he's so just happy about life and
when he does stuff like this is like
he's still happy about being a pimp he's
doing the thing you asked him to do and
he's just like taking it to the end
that's what makes so funny the the time
that they pranked him we have another
video of I know that what the hell are
you doing it's time to stop get back to
my place who's the man now I'm gonna
take your car well I'm in the car now
butters where are you now oh oh
that's cool there's a prostitute out
here okay but is this car Detroit okay
I've got a buddy I'm taking your money
Oh dad me me let's get back to my room
the ferry crosses are destabilizing I
can't I can't break you good I can't see
you oh I think I overdid it I think they
say God what the hell
thanks if you're in like a VR world you
absolutely start to do just monstrous
things but in the reality strangers are
very strong and you can't kill them and
take their money
[Laughter]
if I were in like a West world situation
I think I'll go to Jordan I talked about
this I think we'd be too scared right oh
yeah Gary its Carol Jordan and I were
both in Westworld all we would do is
just we'd play cards and maybe be like
the food's pretty good
horrified no one touch me like if one of
the sex workers and the solution came up
to us you know that's so kind no I said
yesterday on the on the Twitter show
that I about the time that I got
solicited by a prostitute or sex worker
but when I was playing Pokemon go yeah
probably knew you're playing Pokemon
goes like this guy needs get laid has
anyone else ever had the encounter with
that you know what happens a lot which
is not like approached to be like let's
have sex pay me but when I was going to
bars I would all like the game would be
used on me all the time or like
attempted where I was like oh this is
crazy how ubiquitous it is it would
always be like hey and they like try to
like move you so you're like not close
to an exit point and then they're like
tell me something interesting about you
like it was just all this horrible weird
but I was like I see through all this
cuz I'm a good student and I read the
gay question is Jordan ever bought you
ice cream the other thing I will say is
like the comment I always got that I was
like this is so lame is guys would be
like you know what actually I think your
glasses are really cool oh do you know
how many people have told me that you
see actually factually yeah like I'm
such a big person like I see past the
fact that your eyes are broken I always
get that above my hat people are always
nagging we have a normal cool hat that I
wear your ears are cold whatever
lose a lot of your heat through your
head you don't have to cover your ears
it's just science YouTube shoutout
hey we talked about Lady gaga do you
think that every different time she
changed her look it's just actually a
different Gaga like robots across the
world he just fired them off like I am
[Music]
okay Carlos Lanza you said you attack
our guy guy get and we will destroy you
with our clone army travel predictions
for tonight's episode coming up next
but right now something different if
you're in a group chat and not also in a
separate thread talking about the
group chat that means everyone else in
the group chat is talking about you
I suppose vape juice on my pants what
are you vaping right now you do a little
tiny tiny tiny oh the O's is so little
you see it tonight South Park like I
said earlier butters always like takes
it to like the farthest you know what I
mean that something can go I think he's
gonna like really get in cahoots with
big vape or something oh you think he's
gonna become like it what is happening I
think he's gonna become like a
corporation like giant who knows like
how to get kids addicted to nicotine all
right head over to Twitter to check out
our extra damn day show and as always
like share comment subscribe and like
and share and comment and subscribe
again thanks for watching every day
[Music]